she went like do you want to come and i
just went no
no
no i don't sophie turner reveals why she
turned down kendall jenner's invite to a
met gala after party
great it's wonderful
the game of thrones star who is
expecting her second child with hubby
joe jonas stopped by the tonight show
starring jimmy fallon and opened up
about attending the big a-list fashion
event last week admitting she still gets
pretty starstruck around celebrities i
can't quite fathom that i'm actually
invited to these things and i'm not like
a competition winner you know
so i
i mean every celebrity i come into
contact with i'd like act up or say
something stupid and and recently it's
been if a celebrity interacts with me i
immediately just shut them down and i'm
like i don't want anything to do with
you and secretly i'm like
i love you
and that's exactly what happened when
kendall approached the 26 year old
actress at the met
i
love the kardashians but i think she's
like she's so gorgeous in real life and
i was so like struck by her beauty and
she like invited me to they were having
like this after party this low-key after
party
and she went like do you want to come
and i just went no
no
no i don't and i'm like why why do i do
this to myself i would love to come but
like no no i'm good no later and then i
just sat in bed and at pasta and i was
like could be somewhere else right now
and just in case there was any doubt
about sophie's love for the reality tv
fam just head over to tic toc for proof
i'm so excited about it back in january
the actress recreated this iconic scene
from keeping up with the kardashians
where kim simply cannot be bothered by
her sister chloe
so jet lagged from australia you are why
because i just came back from australia
so jet lagged from australia you are why
because it just came back from australia
coco gave it her stamp of approval
sliding into the comments with three
crying laughing emojis are you blushing
oh god yeah or i'm sweaty i can't tell
but joe bros fans know this isn't the
first time they've blessed the internet
with the kardashian reenactment
don't be
rude are you kidding me
yep they threw it back to the
kardashians circle like 2008.
don't be [ __ ]
rude when kim bought a bentley her
sisters courtney and chloe mocked her
for being a brat and all hell broke
loose
don't be
rude are you kidding me i swear to god
don't be what are you throwing the thing
on me i'll [ __ ] hurt you joe
recreated that scene with the help of
his brothers nick and kevin
don't be
rude are you kidding me i swear to god
don't be what are you throwing the thing
on me i'll [ __ ] hurt you don't do
that oh my god
and when et caught up with a 32 year old
singer last month he dished on his viral
kardashian moments
you're pretty good at tick tock though i
got to tell you i mean we get a lot of
entertainment good i'm um i have fun
with it i i think it is a nice way an
outlet to be able to
connect with my audience but also have
fun and and do a face filter and make
you laugh we do have fun with those um
and i'm usually scrolling through them
like wow this i put it in my saved list
and i'm like one eye open scrolling
through tick tock i'm like all right i'm
gonna save this one for later this is a
funny this would be a good one yes
so jet lagged from australia you are why
because it just came back from australia
[Music]
you